what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here today to cover the Ahsoka
trailer uh yeah got up at like 6 30 in the morning
to make sure my Creed video went live and now it
has been rendered obsolete because apparently
there was a bunch of Star Wars announcements my
wife was like Hey thisoka trailers out well what I
was like yup yup it's in my notifications I called
Michael and John Michael picked up Michael
is here our Star Wars nerd expert so happy
you're here I'm so happy to be here and I told
him on the phone like don't look up any of the
celebration announcements because I might want to
talk about it and uh so I know like the title for
the celebrate I don't know the details but yeah I
know nothing it's really hard being a reject right
now because I need to know right now so you do it
that's why we reject anyway people use the force
to leave a like that would mean a lot let's
see what's going on in this trailer let's go
[Music]
something's coming
something dark
oh my God is it
this is something there she is hey wow for
some War got our first Sabine look huh Chopper
whoa who's that you know that I don't
know that looks like a stiff acolyte
of some kind oh wow with all it's
been a while things have changed
I started hearing whispers
that's a great um is that a cover or something
it's heir to the Empire through the empire
[Music] to prepare for the worst wow wow
this is straight up a Rebels a long time ago
oh it's like bro wow there aren't many left
[Music] was that uh Ezra oh interesting question
it is time to begin again [Music]
[Music]
wait a minute I think I know that
what was that droid's name uh that's the the
Droid who built all the lightsabers it has a
oh my God I I feel like I know the name it's
on the tip of my tongue uh it's gonna come to
me it sounds like it sounds like Harang from
Tekken but it's yes that's exactly what it is
but no is that uh let's rewind it was that
Ezra in the Hologram okay really quick this
thrawn look isn't that the that's like a famous
cover or something yeah I mean that's that's the
cover of uh several yeah books I've never read it
I've seen a lot of them books that's Ezra right
I think so yeah this looks like the guy who
they cast but it's so small yeah it's hard
to they have the uh and they have Sabine
looking at him so I was I would assume
that's Ezra anyway you know what I think
that's a flashback hologram of Ezra Bridger
oh because she's she's looking I think she's on
the fall uh in the little Hideout probably longing
for her old friend okay so let's go through this
a little bit first off I thought the trailer was
excellent yeah uh like just tonally cinematic
wise if it does feel like this is just a sequel
to Rebels which I'm here for which is kind of
surprising to me because I feel like if you
haven't seen Rebels you'll be very much left
out love how Zeb is in Mandalore he's nowhere
I I think I feel very confident we're gonna see
Zeb yeah more than likely because if Hera is out
here that means zeb's coming along for the ride
okay so here what is this is this a Jedi Temple
uh that would appear well so interesting a lot of
the symbols that we're seeing in the background
um if we remember kind of the the time Travel how
Ahsoka was saved in Rebels the wall behind walls
yes names and titles are not my special tickets
that vague memories early in the morning we'll
give you a write-off part of where thrawn uh and
Ezra ended up with the pergil is kind of in this
unknown region uh beyond reachable space okay
and that's the quest of where we're going There's
Something Brewing there um you know the yuzan vong
uh or the grisk as they've been kind of renamed uh
in the comics is kind of why thrawn got involved
in the empire in the first place because there's
this species that represents like an existential
crisis to the Galaxy and the emperor was even
worried and it was like building up to prepare for
it and with the absence of the Empire thrawn and
and his species are kind of on their own uh and I
think that's what Ahsoka is alluding to and I'm so
excited to have like a new foreign big bad in Star
Wars I love the heir to the Empire line oh yeah
what a wonderful reference I think Sabine looks
dope uh like one of my favorite I love cat I'm
just uh I love lethal the lost cat they've seen
lost cats before haven't we yeah this is so real
this is like this is like a puppet yeah the other
ones are like hyper CGI I wonder if this will be
a reoccurring love cat oh man um yeah because if
I think if you look right there to the right you
can see the beginnings of the the famous mural of
the rebels crew and then for for reasons unknown
uh probably the costume just didn't quite work
but uh the Gandalf the White of Ahsoka I think
got cut based on the sure which is sad I was
super here for it um what are the these like
Sith like villains they're not they're not they
can't be inquisitors well it's post inquisitors
um but I mean listen there's there's a lot
of Sith acolytes out there in in the galaxy
my hair looks amazing yeah and they've mastered
the Twilight look yeah oh I it took him about
it I'm kind of curious how they time it all out
because she's a general uh for the new Republic
and like if you've played like squadrons uh
she's a really big part of that and like the
new Republic error so I'm curious as to what
extent she's gonna play I wonder if maybe she
helps them commandeer a vessel or or figure out
a way and I would love to see her all the way
through the other thing that we're not seeing
here is there should be a little kit next to
her in the form of her kid uh with Kanan jarus
okay I don't know who these new people are yeah
but looks like Chloe Grace Moretz but it's not
she doesn't seem like she's doing well mentally
so that's a good sign uh but the Sith here do
look yeah look at the lethal looks so good uh
I do love seeing this brought to life yeah so
so this is cool I mean this is the new republic
government a mon mothma Chancellor uh at this
point in time she looked great for her age she is
not aged today uh we get so much Mothman one thing
that Disney era really runs this is significant
about him it's a strange character to give that
much but I'm so here for it one of my favorites
um she was in Mando season two had a dope duel
with soap that's when we asked where is thrawn
who is oh this is the is this the no it's
not oh is it the it could be is that space
what the hell is it called the wall behind
the Spaceballs Bales what the hell is that
called Greg I'm gonna let you struggle on this
because it's really fun to watch they might be
although I get the sense this might also maybe
be a temple or or a set this looks like a set
oh that's that's kind of interesting uh I mean
look almost looks like an excavation site uh
oh yeah yeah I mean it stands to reason that
there are oh wow she looks so good uh it stands
there isn't that you know outside of the known
Galaxy there are Sith like acolytes and you know
um or maybe something completely different um
this one looks so intimidating yeah I love the
shot that it seems like it's hearkening to that
Rogue one but yeah he's great yeah this looks
so good was the double lightsaber the same one of
the same two people we've seen it is an Inquisitor
lightsaber uh uh do you see the circle yeah I
could see it totally a thousand percent okay
in this really fast moving motion well I don't
know Greg you have better eyes than I do I'm
not seeing the circle well I see the circle now
that's hard Circle because you want to see this
um what is the text say I didn't even like process
Rebel which is great because Jedi Outcast is one
of the best Star Wars games ever made but is she
a Jedi well no she's something more and something
less I love how we got like that goofy ass episode
of episode six of the Mandalorian then we get
this like beautifully yeah this is really hard
to to like and you know why your white her
lightsabers are white right uh now she bled
out the red of the crystals of the inquisitors
that she killed oh okay is that not really sick
uh and this is great because that indicates
we're building lightsabers and I'm so glad he
survived he's like the the Treasure Trove
of knowledge for the Jedi Order and you
remember his name Greg it is not a wrong it
might be uh okay I'm embarrassed uh but it's
really early in the morning so I'm gonna type
in harong Rebels I think it's like you you no
yo you're on to it uh are you
young h y yeah wait wait who Young
you got it yeah
you can see how I got her wrong bro yeah no
it's super Fair a little offensive but super
Fair anyway uh yeah I thought that was a
beautiful trailer all right Ahsoka guys
what did you think about this trailer leave
your thoughts down below thank you Michael
for showing up and being the professor for
us I really appreciate it of course guys I
gotta get this video to you we're running
who's came out like hours ago bye [Music]